You go low, I'll go high.
I have wings, why would I go low?
Great job back there.
Are you gonna say the same thing to me?
Good job.
Thank you.
What was your favorite part about what I did?
Really?
She seems more intense.
It wasn't just wings and blasters, it was
skill.
You know I'm an Avenger now.
Me eat people!
Sorry I'm messing around.
Dr. Pym.
I actually heard what happened to you.
You opened up the Quantum Realm.
That's when this crazy, creepy Ghost who like
walks through walls and stuff, stole your
tech.
Now she wants to take over the world or whatever.
If you want to do something right, you make
a list.
One, we have to team up.
Two, we're gonna have to fight Ghost.
Three, we're gonna track down Ghost.
That seems like it should be part of two.
2A.
Oh, also we have to save the world, that's
major, we can't forget that.
What did I miss?
We were just tiny!
No, I know that.
I just wanna make sure that these guys do.
Just wanted to give me a hug.
Wish me luck.
Really?
Yeah.
I wish I could fight bad guys like you.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm talking Ant-Man And The Wasp
deleted scenes.
There were plenty of jokes and moments cut
from the movie, including more Quantum Realm
scenes.
Just before I start, remember my Marvel giveaway
is running for all my subscribers.
To enter, let me know your top three deleted
scenes you wish had been included in the movie.
Of course, spoilers ahead for Ant-Man And
The Wasp so take care if you haven't seen
it.
It was cool to see the Quantum Realm explored
a bit further in the Ant-Man sequel; however,
by the end of the movie, fans were left with
unanswered questions about this other dimension.
And that could be because there are some deleted
and extended Quantum Realm scenes which director
Peyton Reed has said will appear on the Blu-ray.
In fact, Reed said that we should pay attention
to what Janet van Dyne has been wearing while
in the Quantum Realm because she's privy to
some technology and things which the Blu-ray
deleted scene will explain a little.
I'm expecting we'll get some answers as to
how Janet survived there so long or a clearer
idea of how the Quantum Realm works in the
MCU.
Now, let's watch this cut scene carefully,
because I think this is an alternate opening
flashback scene with Hank Pym and Janet van
Dyne.
Notice that Wasp has Janet's red suit in this
scene.
The final film opens with a flashback scene
to a younger Janet and Hank saying goodbye
to their daughter before leaving on a mission.
After suiting up, they arrive at the missile
site just as it's being launched.
This deleted scene looks like it's from an
earlier extended version of that flashback
and it seems to fit with reports that the
movie's opening scene was completely reshot
after testing badly with audiences in early
screenings.
According to reports, it appears the original
opening was set in South America.
This cut scene from the trailer hints that
the alternate opening could have seen Hank
and Janet investigating what was going on
before the missile actually launched.
There are several deleted moments that would
have played up more the tension between Scott
and Hope in a sort of comedic one-upmanship
or battle of the sexes.
You go low, I'll go high.
I have wings, why would I go low?
Great job back there.
Are you gonna say the same thing to me?
Good job.
Thank you.
What was your favorite part about what I did?
Really?
She seems more intense.
It wasn't just wings and blasters, it was
skill.
You know I'm an Avenger now.
Me eat people!
Sorry I'm messing around.
Giant-Man's appearance in Captain America:
Civil War was one of the humorous highlights
of the airport battle, so I think many fans
were hoping for something similar in Ant-Man
And The Wasp.
Now, don't get me wrong, I did enjoy Giant-Man
in this sequel, but seeing him joke around
to scare the ferryboat passengers would have
been a nice added touch to the scene we saw
in the movie.
Peyton Reed has also said there will be extra
Walton Goggins deleted scenes on the Blu-ray.
I can see why Sonny Burch had scenes cut from
the final film as his character didn't seem
entirely crucial to the plot.
However, there are some unanswered questions
about who Burch was actually working for,
with fans theorising it could be a former
MCU villain such as the HYDRA agent trying
to buy the Yellowjacket tech in the first
movie, Justin Hammer, or the Roxxon Oil Corporation.
It'll be interesting to see if we get any
details on this on the Blu-ray.
Ant-Man and the Wasp teaming up!
Dr. Pym.
I actually heard what happened to you.
You opened up the Quantum Realm.
That's when this crazy, creepy Ghost who like
walks through walls and stuff, stole your
tech.
Now she wants to take over the world or whatever.
We all love Luis's hilarious storytelling
style and while we did see Hank Pym meet with
Luis in the film, the trailer also used these
alternate lines.
It might be that, similar to the Ant-Man and
the Wasp teaming up line, this was a version
that Marvel thought worked better in the trailers
to help explain the rough plot of the film.
Luis's mention of Ghost wanting to take over
the world seems like a bit of amusing exaggeration,
but it could mean something more if we take
into consideration this next deleted moment.
Scott, we unleashed something powerful.
This is a curious line from Hope which never
appeared in the movie.
And I can see why it was cut because it doesn't
make a lot of sense in the context of the
final film.
It might suggest Hank and Hope already knew
about Ghost when they first pick up Scott
and were somehow responsible for her predicament,
which would be a different kind of backstory
for the movie's villain.
Paul Rudd's comedy background and his co-writing
credit on the sequel means there are more
unused jokes in the trailers that were maybe
chopped because of run-time and some repetition.
As well as a superhero training montage, the
following moments were also cut:
If you want to do something right, you make
a list.
One, we have to team up.
Two, we're gonna have to fight Ghost.
Three, we're gonna track down Ghost.
That seems like it should be part of two,
2A.
Oh, also we have to save the world, that's
major, we can't forget that.
What did I miss?
We were just tiny!
No, I know that.
I just wanna make sure that these guys do.
Just wanted to give me a hug.
Wish me luck.
Really?
Yeah.
We had a lot of hints about Cassie's future
in the MCU in the sequel, but this is an alternate
line that also suggests Cassie's likely upcoming
role as the Marvel hero Stature.
I wish I could fight bad guys like you.
Marvel has already cast an older version of
Cassie for Avengers 4 where I expect we'll
see her reunite with her father Scott.
For more on that and my other Ant-Man and
Avengers 4 theories, tap the card in the top
right or click the link in the video description.
A missing character reported as appearing
on some Ant-Man And The Wasp promo art at
the Consumer Electronics Show was a robotic-style
assistant, which was speculated could be a
riff on HERBIE from the Fantastic Four comics.
Of course, Marvel doesn't have the cinematic
rights to anything related to the Fantastic
Four yet and the robot character never appeared
in the movie.
Now, what are your three favourite deleted
scenes from the movie?
And how much did you enjoy the sequel?
Let me know what you think and make sure you're
subscribed and hit the bell to enter my Marvel
giveaway.
By the way, I've got a bonus giveaway for
Skyscraper out now.
You can win this awesome GoPro HERO6 Camera.
Click the Gleam link in the video description
below to enter!
Tap left to check out my theories about Avengers
4 and Captain Marvel or tap right for more
deleted scenes like Avengers: Infinity War,
Jurassic World 2 and Black Panther.
If you liked this, I really appreciate a thumbs-up.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!